It's painful to have one man missing, but we can't win at this
rate.Let's leave the useless sloppy alone and take care of it on our own.
Approach the enemy team's crystal with a person
and aim to destroy
it directly.
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa  You say it was definitely more fun when you were
on a date Well, what did
you do?  That's why,
but this
is Sanbon Ahsa, what is that guy? He's
going to attack the crystal while easily blocking it with coalescence magic
.
Cut and dock l 1 door Don't
panic While this crystal is intact, that
crystal is already tattered.
So, we'll become stronger as if we're going home together.
I'll lead the way.